us präsident joe biden wie fremd und
zugleich wunderbar das klingt hat seine
erste arbeitswoche in washington hinter
sich eine neue zeit bricht an uns von
der heute-show müssen zum beispiel auch
endlich inhaltlich relevante gags zu joe
biden einfallen nicht immer nur die
durchgenudelt ein opa witze ach kommt
ist die erste woche auf eine art hat der
neu ist ja sogar leicht nach vier jahren
trump hängt die erwartung zlatan
präsidenten so niedrig wie noch nie
na klar erstmal muss ich jetzt natürlich
den ganzen irrsinn des vorgängers
zurückdrehen
er kehrt er ins pariser klimaabkommen
zurück sagt wurz ein grad kühler
danach stoppte den mauerbau zu mexiko
und kündigt dann die wöchentliche
selbstbräuner lieferung ins weiße haus
siebzehn erlasse an einen tag nicht
schlecht für einen 78 jährigen
jetzt haben wir wirklich auch
versprochen übrigens die wichtigste
veränderung im oval office war natürlich
das hier knopf für den cola light butler
wo ist der gag sowas habe ich hier seit
jahren wirklich hier immer unten cola
mango lassi hier kommt ein käsefondue
und die wichtigste taste lacher
ja ich brauche das einfach für mein ego
wenn der planet atmet durch und genießt
jetzt diese völlig ungewohnte normalität
im weißen haus ja auf einmal ist alles
normal wird denn jetzt alles gut
natürlich nicht über 74 millionen
amerikaner haben ja trump gewählt der
tramp ismus lebt also und ob das zweite
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen den man
erfolg hat das weißt ja auch noch keiner
worum geht es da noch mal ran from
inside the direction ins action against
the united states
ihr action in selection steife leistung
von chuck schumer
und wer weiß vielleicht geht stramm 2024
dort einmal ins rennen könnte sein im
moment hängt er wahrscheinlich in
florida am pool und lässt sich von
michael wendler zum veganen grill am mit
attila hildmann einladen gute gegen
sehen wir das positive in den usa hat
die demokratie trump überlebt wenn auch
nur sehr knapp wie der sturm aufs
kapital beweist der mann hat halt
anhänger die wahlergebnisse nur dann
akzeptieren wenn sie gewinnen wir lassen
doch nicht 51 prozent der amerikaner
bestimmen wie die anderen 49 prozent zu
leben haben
so funktioniert das schlecht so
funktioniert auch demokratie nicht dass
am ende leute reagieren nur weil sie die
meisten stimmung gekriegt haben können
mir jetzt bitte endlich mal über uns
reden was wird aus der deutsch
amerikanischen freundschaft wird da
jetzt alles gut
vorsicht wenn er für uns deutsche war
trump als bösewicht einfach wahnsinnig
praktisch
wir konnten uns bei allen
internationalen konflikten wegducken und
waren trotzdem automatisch die guten
jetzt verhält natürlich wieder
unangenehm auf wo wir nur an uns selber
denken
ich sage nur handelsüberschuss wobei die
merkel ist ja eben mit einem bein in
rente tatsächlich hat joe biden und es
ist ausdrücklich kein witz schon infos
über ihre nachfolge einholen lassen
armin laschet uk is to great greatnet
karl der große boss willi von picasa
minister very very short way am insam
ist ryan gosling we don't know why but
for loving you wanna be kanzler über
next kanzler ist disco crazy king of the
germans are sick unsere noch kanzlerin
hier hat sich übrigens eine super
begrüßungsgeschenk für präsident biden
überlegt ganz kurz vor seiner
vereidigung als ihr noch schnell ohne
rücksprache ein fettes eu
handelsabkommen mit china durchgeboxt
das nennt man wohl perfektes timing oder
musik von der leyen spricht hier von
einer ich zitiere werte basierten
handels agenda mit den chinesen
naja wir teilen so viel werte mit den
chinesen
und dann ist da natürlich noch unser
größter beef mit den vereinigten staaten
wissen sie nord stream 2 putins gasröhre
direkt nach deutschland
die nächste woche finden die amis gar
nicht gut weil sie wollen dass wir viel
mehr teures flüssiggas bei ihnen kaufen
die bedrohen einzelne firmen mit
sanktionen und sogar ein unschuldiges
schiff wäre der fortuna hilft wer ihr
pipelinerohre liefert oder klopapier
muss mit sofortiger strafe der usa
rechnen
gibt es doch nicht sagen was auf schicke
ich morgen auf die fortuna meine
vorletzte rolle
das ist es mir wert aus prinzip wenn
diese sanktionen sind eine
unverschämtheit und verstoßen gegen
völkerrecht wo wir dazu andererseits ist
deutschlands russland-politik auch
komplett fit so überlegen sie mal die
groko die bundesregierung hält ihre hand
über navalny und über gazprom also
letztlich über das system putin und
kontert mecklenburg vorpommerns
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig sie
sagt zitat käme die pipeline nicht aus
russland sondern aus skandinavien gebe
es viel weniger kritik ja weil
skandinavien insgesamt
deutlich weniger oppositionelle umbringt
als putins russland glaube ich egal meck
pomm will die pipeline und wird jetzt
umbenannt in mecklenburg vorpommern
waren sie will das publikum heute ab
geht die zweite nord stream röhre mit
verwaltungsrats gerd schröder war von
anfang an ein fehler wenn ihr jetzt den
bau zu stoppen wo sie fast fertig ist
wäre auch quatsch was macht man dann mit
seiner neuneinhalb milliarden teuren
bauruine vielleicht ein spaßbad rutsche
einfach in russland rein hüpfen 1000
kilometer unter der ostsee hindurch und
hinten mit schmackes wieder raus von da
an nur noch 148 kilometer schwimmen bis
rügen
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat übrigens
errechnet wir bräuchten das zusätzliche
gas gar nicht auch nicht als sogenannte
brückentechnologie
und wenn schon die schwedisch zieht das
jetzt durch um nord stream zwei vor den
us sanktionen zu schützen hat sie sogar
eine stiftung gegründet namens stiftung
klima und umweltschutz mit 20 millionen
finanziert von nord stream / gazprom
eine klimastiftung für erdgas das ist so
als ob können jetzt nicht unbenannt in
stiftung für kälber wohlergehen und
arbeitsplätze in bulgarien
jetzt ist wirklich ein wahnsinn ich
würde das normalerweise ist eine
stiftung klima und umweltschutz sichert
den bau einer gaspipeline
dafür hat man in schwerin sogar ein
forschungslabor eingerichtet geleitet
von dr matthias matschke germanistin und
frau schwesig das nicht peinlich eine
umweltstiftung die von russland
kontrolliert wird hätte diese
unterstellung weise ich entschieden
zurück die stiftung ist komplett
unabhängig genau wie unser labor hier im
manuela putin institut für angewandten
klimaschutz durch sauberes erdgas aus
russland einstellen dass du da als wäre
das hier alles nur eine billige fake
fassade bei uns arbeiten einige der
besten klimaforscher europas und
forschen hochseriös vor sich hin
schauen sie mal das blubbern chemie und
so meine assistentin reicht mir ein
telex aus moskau was manuela schwesig
hat bei twitter erklärt wofür die
stiftung gut ist und hat das mit
kitschiger musik unterlegt
unser schwerpunkt liegt auf der
förderung der klima und umwelt projekte
und ich weiß es liegt vielen menschen in
unserem land am herzen deshalb lade ich
ein diese stiftung mit guten ideen zu
unterstützen
[Musik]
liebe mecklenburger und vorpommer ranzen
haben sie auch gute ideen was könnte
noch dem klima helfen außer erdgas mehr
suv viel mehr fleisch essen schreiben
sie uns keine idee ist zu doof hallo
herr doktor matschke in der satzung
dieser witz stiftung steht vorrangiges
ziel sei die vollendung von nord stream
2 steht da so ja und dann steht die
consumer sich der kag preis bei twitter
hin und erzählt ein vom klima das hat ja
schon gerd schröder qualität sagen sie
mal sammelt der putin eigentlich spd
politiker
jetzt reicht's jetzt schröder ist nicht
käuflich
putin schröder wir reden hier von einer
legendären männerfreundschaft was die
beiden zusammen durchgemacht haben
ich sag nur putins brennende sauna ich
sagte gerhard es brennt wir müssen hier
raus er sagte tut mir leid vorher trinke
ich mein bier noch aus ich sagte bist du
verrückt es brennt wir müssen raus er
ist ein eiserner man ja tatsächlich sein
bier ausgetrunken die sauna brannte
danach bis auf die mauern nieder
der guard ist der härteste wir gehen
hier erst raus wenn der kasten bier alle
ist
da fällt mir ein wir müssen ja weiter
forschen total wichtiges experiment
arbeitstitel wodka saufen gegen den
treibhauseffekt viel glück matthias
matschke
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll auslasten abo
da